je vous le disais en titre coville 19
foire de tours le match retour d'un côté
une pandémie récalcitrantes
de l'autre une très vieille dame qui
fête ses 100 ans cette année
annuler trois fois l'an dernier l'un des
plus gros événements de la région aura
lieu en juillet et non pas en mai
histoire de se donner toutes les chances
la jauge elle sera limitée à 5000
personnes ont fait le point avec romain
d'el vide la foire de tours passent
directement au plan b pour les 100 ans
de l'événement elle aura lieu du 2 au 11
juillet c'est en tout cas le souhait de
la ville et de tours événement qui mise
sur une jauge de 5000 personnes en
simultané des allées plus larges et un
peu moins d'exposants que d'habitude
environ 420 quant à la fête foraine elle
devrait avoir lieu du 25 juin au 18
juillet si la préfecture donne son
accord
évidemment on fait des suppositions on
se décide la situation son maintien
comme c'est aujourd'hui on pourra tenir
la foire la fête foraine avec des jauges
de 5000 places et c'est le pari qu'ont
fait aujourd'hui mais peut-être que dans
un mois on sera confiné on sait pas ou
peut-être que dans un mois on sera
vacciné on pourra commencer à ressortir
on ouvrira les restaurants les bars on
ne sait pas aujourd'hui
l'autre casse-tête organisationnel c'est
le village gastronomique
l'idée première c'est d'espacer les
îlots de vente est de créer un millier
de places assises le village
gastronomique c'est une partie de l'âme
de la fois donc quelque part la crise
que l'on subit nous oblige à avoir
d'autres plantes
b c d e donc de leur l'imagination de la
créativité
donc c'est vrai qu'on essaye de
d'imaginer ce que pourrait être un
village gastronomique qui conserve son
adn dire qu'il soit sympa à vivre mais
dans des conditions d'un protocole
sanitaire qui est complexe
le pari de juillet est risqué il est
optimiste et s'appuie sur les mesures de
l'an passé quand la france était d
confiné momentanément à partir de la fin
juin